hello ladles and jelly spoons I'm Dave
Rubin this is the Reuben report and I've
got two of my favorite all-star
panelists whitney mixter brett erlich
are with me that was that was good we
didn't even that just incredible all
right here we go let's get to it you
probably heard about McDonald's new
mascot it's kind of new it's at least
new here in the United States his name
is happy let's look at happy this guys
happy that is a scary freakin mascot
that's real when I saw this first I
thought it was one of those stories that
you see that you go no that can't
possibly real because that looks scary
to me happy according to the McDonald's
press release is about bringing more fun
and excitement to kids meals including
eating wholesome food like low-fat
yogurt okay now we can we can come back
to us happy just when you look at happy
do you feel happy what is the emotion
that happy brings out in you well I will
say this in my personal hell thousands
of those characters will be charging
towards me with Pharrell's happy playing
on repeat you know the thing is
McDonald's will never be cool and it
will never be healthy they're trying to
like do this new thing where they're
like I've seen some ads where they're
trying to appeal to hipsters recently
I've seen this this looks like some
graphic designer in college was in their
room and like put together this like
very amateur looking graphic to me it's
not it doesn't you know symbolize
anything that is like cool and fresh and
whatever right so I want to get to the
cool and fresh thing but first just
unhappy himself here's the thing how did
they do this I've been happy I've never
been that happy you never have never
been remotely as happy the happy meal
and yeah there's a they're replacing all
the food they're either giving you like
apple wedges in the Happy Meal and maybe
that extra amount of sugar is what puts
them over the top baby I I do it doesn't
look like something professional yeah it
looks like clipart yes it looks like
something a comedy show would make in
order to make fun of a
Happy Meal type mascot yeah is there
something deeply psychological going on
with McDonald's that they have to do
something that bad and over-the-top
because of exactly what your point is
which is they're trying to be something
they're not
so they can't authentically make
something that would feel right I really
think anything the words deep and
psychological cannot be associated with
read on this point any benefits the
doubt yeah definitely yeah definitely
the doubt give them as much of that as
possible it's crazy the eyeballs on that
thing
the fact that I mean look at it it's its
eyes are permanently filled back it's
very skinny it has an enormous hat
athletic show itself is very inviting I
feel like I can cozy up in there for
hours like the Dodgers
yeah those teeth right the veneer teeth
the eyes peeled back the skinniness with
you it's Bruce Jenner
there's no elbows like eat happy meals
and you will have no bones in your arm
no bones in just an incredibly large
torso yeah it's just so this this kind
of gives me positive reinforcement that
people have caught on to McDonald's
because when I was that when I was a kid
we would eat Happy Meals all the time
because that was just what you did in
the eighties E and we'd have we'd have
birthdays parties there remember the
birthday breakfast at McDonald's with
pancakes and now people are on to them
and they have to resort to these very
strange things and it's almost like
someone who is the age of Ray Kroc was
like what a kids like cartoons give them
one use a computer so that's what it is
what you started this by saying that we
all are on to the thing that they're
doing now so it has to be over the top
they show us hipsters everyone
everyone's always fit in their
commercials also which would be going to
McDonald's generally the people aren't
that fit they're not that happy and all
that they just keep doubling down right
to push the image yeah I think so I mean
you know you never want to run into
someone you know and I McDonald's it's
true like it's not a
social gathering spot it's not the
Starbucks of fast food at all
but those commercials where all those
hip good-looking people are like sending
fries to the girl down there and then
I'm told I mean you know I'm totally
gonna send you some fries later I want
to know you know what I want to know
where is the old-school posse of Ronald
where are they
where's the Hamburglar yeah Hamburglar
they're like shooting heroin in a corner
somewhere like they're like they've
given up on life you know you got fired
from McDonald's what's that everything's
so offensive these days the grimace I'm
sure would offend purple people eat at
McDonald's all the time are the shape of
grimace so you know what I remind people
yeah the Hamburglar you know criminals
yeah you guys do realize that the
commenters are gonna say we're elitist
bastards for making fun of McDonald's
and they would be correct you know I I
applaud McDonald's recent attempts to
like put lettuce and things you know
there's like a green lettuce now as
opposed to like the iceberg version they
used to have right and they offer a
grill a grilled chicken but all the
photos offer grilled chicken branding to
be pressed into other cooks otherwise
cooked meat yeah yeah why don't they
just do the honest thing and just sort
of admit what they are cuz i think that
why don't they just double down on that
instead of the lie that somehow this is
healthy or good for you or fun or happy
why don't they do it look we know this
is fast food like they're not tricking
anybody wouldn't a little honesty be
nice I would go to McDonald's more often
if there was like just like some
overweight guy really sad depressed I'm
giving up on life but I'm gonna enjoy me
a Big Mac one more time I'd be like yeah
okay you know the Olympics comes around
all the Olympians are sponsored by
McDonald's and the thing is those are
the only people who can eat McDonald's
yeah because those are the people who
can eat 5,000 calories a day and still
maintain their physique cuz they're
working out all the time that's funny
you know i remember the old remember the
bird Michael Jordan commercially bounced
off the backboard and everything
remotely like these guys would never eat
McDonald's during the playoffs cuz it's
not like the Olympians where they have
to keep eating just for whatever right
but like there they'll take the money
from McDonald's but that's a whole other
story let's move on let's talk some
politics president obama have you heard
of this guy
he basically announced this week that
he's going to be doing even more
executive orders this is pretty much
because congressional republicans
refused to work with him or do anything
for the government so we have a
statement from Dan Pfeiffer who is
Obama's senior advisory given this
dynamic and what he's talking about is
how the Republicans refused to work with
President Obama President Obama has only
one option to use every ounce of his
authority to unilaterally improve
Economic Security next week as
congressional Republicans spend their
energy on yet another partisan
investigation we'll be picking up the
pace on executive actions to help the
economy we have many more executive
actions to come and every day the
president has charged us with looking
for additional ways to expand
opportunity so he's talking about the
Benghazi hearings that the Republicans
are gonna do I'm a little conflicted by
this because on one hand I think that
the Republicans have been awful and they
don't want to work with the guy and he's
becoming the lame duck every day he gets
closer to to leaving on the other hand I
don't like one branch of government sort
of superseding what its power is where
do you fall there's some great things
that Obama's doing with some of his
executive orders he's created 11
national monuments I really think that
that's the kind of things he has to
pepper in there so he's like listen
these aren't all just me being utilize
em I bounce I'm doing what you're
supposed to do he's created more than
almost three times as many national
monuments as george w bush so he did not
so he's being very effective in doing
things like making it so you can go see
cactus in in a place is protective and
whenever be never be taken apart but i
get it with executive actions in that i
know what like that's okay at least
something's happening and it's fine and
it all comes down to like what is the
overall dynamic and you know if the
republicans are as dedicated to stopping
him from doing things as they say they
are will then they'll kind of find a way
to overrule his executive
orders yeah well I don't think they can
overrule the executive order act didn't
pass something in order to get that to
happen but in the meantime just go for
it and do it yeah do you agree should he
just do this cuz he sorta has no choice
that bad in the law well the thing is
you know these monuments that he's
putting up I must say that it's
interesting how he's kind of playing
into the American people with these
monuments because he's kind of like look
at this thing and while you're all here
let me talk about carbon emission
because that's like what he's planning
on doing so you know what I mean you're
getting people's attention you're like
look at this giant thing it's shiny and
it's a monument that you love and while
you're here I'm gonna talk about serious
issues and hopefully pepper that and you
know so I gotta give him credit for that
I agree with you though I don't I don't
feel like I don't want to see this
become some type of dictatorship of
course but you know I think I think
politics is kind of like this political
whack-a-mole that happens you know it's
like people don't do things so he's
taking executive orders and then the
next guy is gonna come in and you know
be able to overturn the things that he
put in so it's just gonna happen but
that'd be balances itself out so that
nothing ever changes and also that being
said you know Franklin Roosevelt which
was considered by many one of the most
popular presidents of all time the
amount of executive orders that he made
what Obama has done that was like his
afternoon tea time of executive order so
you know right so they do go crazy about
I'm glad you brought that up because
they go crazy constantly on Fox News
about executive orders and you're right
he hasn't done as many although he's do
I don't think he's done even as many as
George he's about equal but you know
George Bush made some pretty hefty
executive orders happen you know that
whole like stem cell research or
presidential you know being able to hide
things within the presidency you know
Iraq you know things like that so so if
this was a Republican right now a
Republican president who you really
didn't like and the Democrats were
stonewalling his whole thing would you
be more pissed about this the president
going and doing it no no not really
you're being intellectually honest I
mean allegedly honest I don't you know
when I'm one of those people who really
gets up in arms when it
like running against each other I like
that more I think I fall in line with
most Americans when it comes to that and
and in terms of whack-a-mole like as
soon as something big happens then I'll
say like that specific thing was
terrible but I don't think the average
person is you know and rightfully
because they have so much else to worry
about paying enough attention for this
to really kind of come to the forefront
of their daily lives so I kind of fall
into that I have way too much housewives
to watch so speaking of that how much
final thought on this how much of this
is just drama it's just sort of this
endless drama that they're replaying
over and over and nobody believes what
they're saying and they're just doubling
down on party things and money I don't
know it's all drama and there's always
like one new move that people are using
you know there's always when when you
get to gridlock you have to do something
different and in this situation the
gridlock is happening and so the
president is trying to do something
different to get around it and just as
when they were going head-to-head trying
to get things passed through Congress
people try different things like this is
something he said well I can actually do
this so I'm gonna go forward and do it I
feel like the Republicans are kind of
pouting on the playground right now and
he was like well while you're doing that
I'm gonna go handle business so you
can't be mad there you go I like okay
people can you please not bring your
guns into Chipotle that's what they're
requesting after a bunch of guys carried
military-style assault rifles into a
Chipotle franchise in Dallas Texas they
were promoting their open carry laws
because you're allowed to if you have a
gun you're allowed to openly exhibit it
and bring it around into public spaces
but Chipotle would just prefer you not
do that they even issued a statement the
display of firearms in our restaurants
has now created an environment that is
potentially intimidating or
uncomfortable for many of our customers
of course it went on to go on and on and
say you know so please don't bring guns
into chipotle we'll give you the the
guacamole but we're gonna charge you
extra they make a big point of that
really make another extra yeah like I
know it's like a moment we're done its
guacamole it's not free this is American
nectar of the
gods I understand it's gonna be at a
premium yes so these people that are
bringing the guns there
these are assault rifles these are not
just none not just a handgun at a
fast-food giant deserve assault rifles
but they have a right to do it so before
we get jokey and Lybia about them should
we defend their right to bring their
weapons I mean you know I'm slightly
intimidated by saying you know I don't
know if somebody's gonna come out and
like you know pull their weapons on me
cuz good lord
reading all of the comments underneath
these articles there is a large amount
of people who really want that second
amendment amendment upheld Jesus you
know I think that there needs to be some
type of parameter set though you know
it's not like like can I just push like
my cannon in through the door but like
just saying this is busy you know I'm
here to openly carry one for me yeah and
I feel really bad for the you know
burrito wrappers that need to come out
and you know calmly ask Billy Bob to
like put their assault weapon back in
the truck like it just doesn't seem like
a fair pairing but yeah so if you went
into Chipotle and there was two guys
sitting there with assault rifles on the
table what would you do
well I went to Costa Rica to a Pizza Hut
and there was a guy outside with an
assault rifle and it freaked me the hell
out but he was just a guard he was just
a guard and he had an assault rifle I
get it I mean yes these are it's tough
when it's like the way in which you
display your right is really scary yes
you know that's what everyone's afraid
of and I think they should solve this
all by having different kinds of
Chipotle's there's Capote Lay's where
you can't have guns and then there's
Chipotle's where you can only have guns
and there's like an all gunship outlay
like a battle royale chipotle well I
like the normal cheapo like they have
they'll have these ones that have only
everyone has a gun and then the normal
Chipotle's where they have that
trademark Chipotle knife fight every so
often right so basically in the south
that's where the gun ones are
knife fights we're gonna die oh there's
lots of guns in all kinds of cities I
feel like people you know I just I just
want I you know it's that I I want them
to be able to have their right on
display but I mean it's weird where are
you gonna put your assault rifle in the
car outside I mean you want it with you
you don't want someone stealing that
yeah part of the problem though that
when we have these talks about guns that
the comments section always it's
everyone demanding their right that they
immediately if you even talk about this
and say that maybe you shouldn't be
allowed to bring an assault rifle into
Chipotle they immediately take that as
they're coming for our they can refuse
your service if you have no shirt
exactly but if you're carrying your
assault rifle with no shirt no shoes
maybe they'll have to are you and now I
don't know I mean I think that there
needs to be a balance had which is you
can carry a concealed weapon which would
make sense you know you have it on you
still why do you need to look like
you're laughing around I just don't
understand Joe goes yeah I look at you
would small penis and for you this is
really I know I I can still get diarrhea
Chipotle which it happens all the time
really I love Chipotle yeah I have to
poop I think I just swallowed like
that's how fat like the Four Seasons
I don't know it's just like so spicy
some of this stuff is just so spicy try
the mild so no they always get like a
little tiny thing a jalapeno in there
and it lates your face on fire alright
we're gonna go to Chipotle one of these
days will help with your order okay
we'll go from there we're not gonna
besmirched Chipotle on this go okay
let's move on America might actually be
ready for a gay president some people
say we've had a gay president or two but
yeah a new poll is showing that we might
actually be ready for it this is by Pew
Research Center for the people in press
let's take a look the majority of
Americans 66 percent say it wouldn't
matter for presidential candidate was
gay or lesbian
that's nice 27% say they would be less
likely to support a gay or lesbian
candidate while 5% would be more likely
and in 2007 nearly half said they would
be less likely to vote for a gay or
lesbian candidate so this doesn't really
surprise me that much a lot of good gay
stuff has been happening just in the
last week what we get one of these
activist judges they took down
Pennsylvania is now gonna have gay
marriage and Oregon so yeah good gay
things are happening want you to have a
segment called good gay stuff good gay
stuff good guys who could be the token
straight guy yeah as the ambassador for
the lesbian community you must feel good
about this you could now run you can now
be president I this is actually I
actually planned this segment to take a
moment to talk to the American people
about my run 2014 no I feel really
excited about that
so I like that we gave no specifics
about your which means it's gonna be
good it's good no I think I think it is
very telling of where we're coming in
this country I think we've made huge
steps leaps forward really in the past
couple years and I think now people are
realizing it doesn't matter who you are
you're probably going to [ __ ] up you
know yeah I get it yeah we've had plenty
of straight presidents and they've still
managed to focus yes so you know you
better issue your apology why I think
it's great I think that's a good I think
that's the joke that's why I became
president yeah right that's another
thing that could be that's my campaign
slogan you will get shafted here
I'm fine do you think so I think it's
obviously great right of course it is so
yes well maybe we'll have a gay
president probably within our lifetimes
fantastic
do you think the biggest hurdle actually
will be the the public display of
affection thing because that's still the
part that is not shown for gay people
even though there's been a huge you know
what it's really awkward to watch most
presidents be affectionate like I mean I
think Obama is the first one that kind
of has like some swag with his lady
First Lady yeah but you know George W
Bush that was weird it's like an awkward
I'm like what is their sex like you
remember that horrible ow Al Gore kiss
remember god bless Al Gore I remember
that Gore Gore it was that that was 2000
yeah it was that one where it was like
listen I'm not a robot I'm sexual as
hell down and he did it and it was just
so gross and long yeah and it was just
strange and I get that I mean and and
there's this I don't think that anyone
is being those those public displays of
affection regardless of gender like I
think those are still kind of creepy no
man and I think everyone finds like a
middle ground where if it's like a
tasteful display then it's okay then
it's tasteful but it's it's hard to
define it ahead of time but once then it
goes overboard you gotta understand yes
we're agreed that that's pretty gross no
matter who it is do you think it would
be easier to have a gay male or a
lesbian first my gut feeling is we'd
probably have a lesbian first why
Hillary Clinton know it might be easier
but then we're talking we're not only
electing our first woman but she's gonna
be a lesbian hey again I'm running for
president now I think it's possible I
mean I don't know on one hand I feel
like people would be more apt to you
know vote for a man I don't know I mean
historically it's been the case but I
think people will feel more
uncomfortable with seeing that kind of
right I just feel like the emotions
aren't uncomfortable with having a gay
leader that guy
yeah we're always with the shirt like
where are we is this with Hollywood what
are we doing yeah come on yeah Justin
Bieber yeah alright well that no Putin's
gay okay let's everybody gets cold
enough and Russia I just got caught it's
cold enough it's really really good
alright so neil degrasse tyson you
probably know him he has become sort of
america's scientist he's doing cosmos on
Fox right now which is really really
fantastic if you're not watching you
should be watching it so he brought up
on his radio show on Startalk radio
that basically we shouldn't be giving
equal time to climate change deniers as
we're giving to actual scientists who
believe in climate change he was talking
to CNN's Miles O'Brien let's take a
listen accuracy in journalism that leads
to what's that what's this phrase is it
fair and balanced I had to ask Myles
what's this fair and balanced movement
that we've been hearing about let's
check it out some stories have one side
that is represented by say 95% of the
scientific community of the world is it
fair in a story about climate change
which I'm obviously talking about to do
this classic journalistic convention of
equal time for both sides this is a huge
mistake I think for journalists I get
95% and then there's the 5% you get a
person from that 5% I'll get 50% of your
time is that serving the truth I would
submit to you not as a matter of fact
that is feeding obfuscation that is
actually perpetuating a myth dare I say
a lie
all right I am completely with you Miles
O'Brien here's the thing if you watch
cosmos every animated section of cosmos
is a and I'm not saying that any of
these people are right if every animated
section is about how this guy said
something that no one believed and no
one would listen to him and had they not
listened to that and they you know
continued not to listen to this one
percent then we would never have gravity
or whatever the hell so there's
something fundamentally wrong about the
logic here yes I get that like you're
using their own argument against them
climbing the night there's there's a
better argument against letting idiots
speak yeah you know then then
this one this the logic here doesn't
doesn't play out because like every
scientific idea that has ever been
adopted on the large scale started with
a small scale so you can't go with the
95 to 5 aspect of it you know a hundred
percent of people thought the world was
flat until they proved it wrong so
that's that's just an illogical thing I
think deGrasse Tyson again
also if you watch this show the cosmos
you get that thing like some people have
been picked on all their lives and when
they get to be cool they just are cool
Neil deGrasse Tyson still is pissed at
people like he is now like meeting out
his vengeance on folks and he gets like
he takes like way too long on the cosmos
to talk about these idiot climate
deniers like alright I agree with you
there is like a 5% like rubbing in their
nose kind of thing I actually I don't
mind it what do you think should when
when we talk about climate change or
what CNN and all the networks basically
do all them is they give 50 50 no matter
what is based in science if 97% of the
scientists agree seems like the other
guy shouldn't get 50 percent yeah I mean
fair and balanced journalism and but are
we talking like does that mean that Fox
just doesn't exist as a news reporting
channel like because I feel like I do
they provide a 50/50 fair and balanced
I'm sure they're not giving 50 percent
right and probably find the numbers but
I doubt they're giving 50 percent to the
climate change no I mean I mean in
general journalism if he's talking about
journalism is supposed to be based on
you know an equal time and perspective
of viewpoints or accuracy at all I just
don't feel as though you know fak should
even be existing in this world if that's
the case but it's and actually speaking
of Fox they actually just it the fact
that they just came out and said
actually said that climate change is
real that should a hundred percent go go
take that last 3% and just prove that
the Antarctic is currently melting into
ourselves right now there's a piece of
the Antarctic that's like what do they
say it's like 20 times the size of
Manhattan right just fell off and it's
melting and there's nothing we can do or
Miami's gonna disappear so how do we
honestly have a debate about is there
any debate is there any purpose of
having a debate I think I agree
the proportion of time spent talking
like of people who know what they're
talking about people who don't know what
they're talking about
I get that the proportion is off and
they should adjust who is allowed to
speak for how long but I think we need
to go the other way of what Neil
deGrasse Tyson is saying I think we need
to let the idiots speak longer because
that's the most entertaining thing for
me it give them 95% of the time because
it's entertaining because it's so stupid
and then you let an idiot talk for long
enough and they'll put their foot in
their mouth and no expose how stupid so
that's sort of the theory that you know
Bill Nye the Science Guy did the debate
with the guy from the creation thing and
he believed that Jesus was riding a
dinosaur basically and a lot of people
that's what they were saying well he
just let him hang himself
so that's your like John Oliver did that
thing where he let he brought on 97
scientists to debate against three non
weird weirdo jesus' should we have a
scientist be president we were just
talking about we could maybe have a gay
president do you think maybe it's time
that we great scientists not with that
that's a very nature ya know really good
if you like a scientist president like
someone who's actually based in fact and
not in yeah I think that that would be a
great idea I'm going to take the next
couple months to go get my doctorate
back do you want to tell the camera
again like you did I will be studying
very hard for the next four months don't
worry I'll be back to be your first
scientific lesbian president all right
we got one more for you let's talk about
net neutrality we've been doing this
every week because this is the most
underreported story in the mainstream
news they are dropping the ball surprise
surprise the FCC flip net neutrality net
neutrality was basically the principle
that everyone had equal access to the
Internet and the Internet service
providers couldn't throttle your
internet based on the companies that
they are connected with that is no
longer even though Obama said he was for
net neutrality he appointed a telecom
lobbyist who was also a campaign bundler
and the guy flipped net neutrality you
can check that out if you don't believe
me
the Sunlight Foundation published a
series of great
explaining lobbyists spending on net
neutrality and I think it pretty much
explains the whole damn thing so giant
companies the internet companies like
Verizon AT&T and Comcast the big boys
they basically the red what you're
seeing there these are reports that they
issued through their lobbyists that were
against net neutrality and then somehow
net neutrality got flipped and if that's
not enough of proof for you about what's
going on here that this is just about
money let's look at the next one this is
the total lobbying expenditures of the
top 20 organizations with the most
reports mentioning that neutrality and
yeah if you're against net neutrality
you spent a [ __ ] load of money on
reports lobbying politicians and then as
we talked about a couple weeks ago there
was a Senate Commission on net
neutrality and literally every senator
on the Commission had taken money from
Comcast and the only one who fought
against it was Al Franken because he had
taken the least amount of money so if
you don't know what's going on here it's
pretty obvious at this point so I'm
gonna keep talking about net neutrality
even though I feel like the ship has
sailed and it's really sad what what
should we do for people that exist in
this online space and it's the last
vestige of freedom in this freaking
country slowly the reports people
putting out and port after report like
if someone gives me thousands of reports
I hate that [ __ ] why is that working
that should not be working what is it
with politicians they love report I was
thinking the same thing like does that
ever get to the politician himself like
they just hand them a [ __ ] stack of
paper yeah oh this report on sir by the
bad guy I just think I think it's like a
report cool where's that money again
yeah that's so it's so frustrating it's
it's there should be the problem what's
so frustrating is the money that they're
using to buy this influence comes from
people who are using their service
viewers like you who are losing who are
basically paying to pay more later
that's so frustrating yeah and I
honestly don't know what the solution is
there
is no real sameen but it works the same
way any resource works where the my you
know the people who have who are
controlling how its doled out and the
scarcity of it have all the control yeah
because what are we gonna do like I mean
there's there's no I can't even have
like you know bunny ears on my antenna
anymore and you know so Time Warner it
makes me have a box inside my house
right so literally what was free the
free to get the basic channels of like
ABC Fox whatever that was free and then
they went digital so you can't not have
just free television what is public
service you can't even get that any yeah
it's it's it's one of the most
frustrating things because it's such a
complicated process that is unfolding
not before our very eyes somewhere
tucked very deep away and that we can't
even get to under it's like my freakin
credit report like I don't even know how
that works but it's affecting my life
you know yeah I mean it was bad this has
been heaven I mean this type of thing
has been going on in every facet of big
business and the Internet is the biggest
you know channeler of information and
commerce now and it was just a matter of
time where things are regulated by kind
of monopolized by the big guys you know
and you're right we don't understand how
does this thing work I don't know it was
in a series of tubes also speaking of
the simple days are we gonna look back
at this time and I've asked this before
when we've done this but will we look
back at this sort of 2002 just about now
as the as the glory days of the internet
like 10 years from now when it's all
really controlled and throttled and
you're paying per whatever purview or
per data are we gonna look back and go
wow it was pretty good back then it was
pretty good it was evil playing no this
isn't this is being made before thank
you got it but it is very yes this is
the Golden Age right now because right
essentially what we had in terms of you
know the way people the kind of content
that people want to enjoy typically is
like video content right and or at least
their you want to read it on your own
but if you compare it to the way cable
used to cable
works is there's tears of cable so if
you want to watch all that but that
whole model of cable is disappearing and
so the telecom still want a tiered
system so they can charge you for more
and what's happening now is our ability
to get around all of that all these
people who are like listen I just want
to sign up for Hulu and Netflix and have
it on my watch are totally winning
they pay so much less every month and
right now the telecoms are realizing
that and they want to still have that
model and they're trying to you know get
it that way and they have all this money
from the old system and they're just
gonna go for it yeah and if you don't
think the old system and the telecoms
are screwed up there was just a report
issued this week about how our internet
in America is like one of the worst for
industrialized nations so we're not even
getting good service in the first place
but I guess we don't even know it
because when was the last time you guys
were in Korea South Korea to check out
North Korea the other day yeah well on
that note I hope you learned a little
something here maybe you got a little
dumber maybe I laughed a little bit
we'll see I'm gonna let you to pimp
yourselves out I'm what new mixture and
I will be your future president dr
whitney mixter that is and aside from
that I'm on the Twitter whitney mixter
la instagram whitney mixter la and you
could check out my blog at
www.att.com/biz www break give us some
w's hi what's up my name is george w
bush ah
my name is brett erlich and i'm not
running for president i know for a fact
i could not do the job you can see me at
twitter.com slash brett erlich
and you can watch me on pop trigger on
the young turks network on youtube also
we do it on hulu once a week so you can
do that
yeah at least until the internet crashes
and they take us all down okay